I'm a general partner and a founding
partner at lul ventures we're an early
stage VC based in Tel Aviv um our
background is entrepreneurial uh you
know we've been fortunate enough to go
through the Journey twice successfully
building tech companies that became
Global category leaders and got
acquired um you know maybe we can touch
about on that a little bit more later
but but you know just to answer your
question uh having been on both sides of
the of the table in a way um at L we
really strive to add value to the to the
founders we work with uh given our
background given our experience given
the fact we've been on both sides of the
table
building you know exiting working for
Global corporates for four or five years
After exiting to them uh seeing how it
works from the other side as as
executive and and Global public
companies twice um you know I think that
that that brings to the table a a
variety of uh let's call it
[Music]
perspectives welcome to a 20 minute
leaders I'm really really excited to be
spending the next 20 minutes with you
really diving into your journey
co-founder General partner at at L
Ventures you're an entrepreneur yourself
um youve experienced the Myriad of
opportunities within within the
entrepreneurial Journey uh from from
entrepreneur executive manager of the of
of an important site H to all the way to
to investing and to sitting on Boards of
other entrepreneurs who've successfully
built and sold their companies and so
I'm really excited to dive into the
Myriad of of experiences and and key
learnings that you've had um so so if
you know if we really start high level
aai how do you consider yourself today
what is really your your main role right
so so first Matias thanks for having me
I'm really excited to to be here and
share from my
experience um listen to to to your to
your question uh today um I'm a general
partner and a founding partner at L
Ventures we're an early stage VC based
in Tel Aviv um our background is
entrepreneurial
uh you know we've been fortunate enough
to go through the Journey twice
successfully building tech companies
that became Global category leaders and
got
acquired um you know maybe we can touch
about on that a little bit more later
but but you know just to answer your
question uh having been on on both sides
of the the table in a way um at L we
really strive to add value to the to the
founders we work with uh given our
background given our experience given
the fact we've been on both sides of the
table table
building you know exiting working for
Global corporates for four five years
After exiting to them uh seeing how it
works from the other side as as
executive and and Global public
companies twice um you know I think that
that that brings to the table a a
variety of uh let's call it
perspectives uh that help us help
founders
identify and really navigate through
this this very challenging journey of
Entrepreneurship you know it's it's very
you know uh exciting everybody's is
thinking about you know being an
entrepreneur as as something that they
they aspire to but you know clearly uh
it's not an easy Journey it's a tough
Journey it's very
complex and as mentors and and this is
what we see ourselves we see ourselves
as mentors that can bring to the table a
lot of value uh to Founders that that
that are less experienced young uh and
and are eager to learn and succeed fast
and accelerate fast absolutely and I
think that I mean this this notion of
it's a challenging journey I understood
it you know myself now as an
entrepreneur I i' as an as an investor
I've always understood it I grew up in a
house of entrepreneurs until you get to
experience it yourself you really get
surprised I think by by the complexities
with which we're dealing with in the
day-to-day that that are just unique to
every situation and in somehow are also
very similar and so I can only imagine
um you know what what you bring to the
table but connect connect the dots from
from your experience so as an
entrepreneur and executive and now
investor and board member what are the
ways in which you really interact with
entrepreneurs that you enjoy most and
you feel reap the most benefits to them
in the complexities of the
entrepreneurial Journey yeah that's a
great question so so of course you know
let's talk from the talk first on on the
technical aspects and Technical touching
points between us and the founders uh
those are not necessarily the the place
where we bring the highest value but we
do have board meetings uh you know uh
usually three four times a year with
every company we invest in um that is a
more strategic discussion but we tend to
do you know as far as our philosophy is
value Ed we we have two other types of
major engagement and third one that is
totally casual so let's start with the
easy one and the totally casual we're
always available on WhatsApp any time of
the day to address any pressing
questions okay uh and that accessibility
is very important in our view okay uh
the two additional most structured
processes one is an intimate discussion
you know each founder I'm working with
has a has a you know a weekly or a
bi-weekly slot on my calendar okay um
that could be a coffee meeting that
could be a zoom usually it's alter
alternates between um it's a meeting
where we sit around the table we pull up
our sleeves we get a quick update what
are pressing
issues um we discuss them we look at
data okay data Trends graphs you know of
of pressing topics and and key key
indicators for the business but it's an
open discussion you know it could be
anything that's on your mind okay it
could be a hiring issue it could be a
fundraising issue it could be a
strategic view on the business that is
where most of the value is generated to
be honest with you okay it's very
intimate no strings attached it's not
formal like a board where you have to be
formal with a lot of things and
everything you say is kind of you know
uh this is like really really really
we're on the same side of the table in a
way okay and how do you feel the the how
how do can you can you dive a little bit
deeper into how the inform informat of
the relationship and the fact that you
also are an entrepreneur yourself you're
both both an entrepreneur within the VC
world but you're also you've also
founded and led companies so what are
the types of informalities that you
exchange with entrepreneurs that you
feel really Drive value to them either
on the on the personal you know
emotional mental or or tangible
experiential aspects yeah yeah so so
just to finish the third the third item
and I'll get back to that and there
there is something we call Value
creation process which is a bit more
structured okay so we have the WhatsApp
we have the board these are the two
extreme WhatsApp totally informal the
board very formal the bi-weekly or
weekly meeting which we're going to
touch more into and then we have
something we call Value creation program
which is more a quarterly discussion
where we kind of elevate to 50,000 feet
and look at where we've been where we're
going on many different facets of the
business and this is mainly focus on
what assets do we need to to bring to
the table for our next fundraising okay
so we look very high level things on
traction unit economic story team and
many other things okay so these are the
processes that we as a fund operate and
this is far as our philosophy to have
multiple views on things some are more
intimate some are more formal okay let's
go back to your question on on the
intimacy listen the main point is the
ability to listen the main point is the
ability to translate okay uh translate
let me give you a couple of anecdotes
okay been you know just not mentioning
Nam specifically but was a company I was
involved with you know that that that
you know was working with a major
American corporation you know Silicon
Valley time time zone like CEO calls me
like 11 pm uh you know Israel time it's
you know he just finished a meeting
there um and he's telling me what
happened in the meeting okay um I
practically you know highlighted to him
that based on my experience have it been
twice working for for public US public
companies you know as I said you know I
exited twice to one once to a French
company to WR in NASDAQ and wants to AOL
America Online um you know I I was able
to explain to them that what they heard
you know was totally wrong to what the
other
party um you know actually could tell
them and navigated through not being
able to tell them exactly what they
wanted to hear essentially they were
trying to sell the company um and what
they heard was uh basically it's not
going to happen and what what I was able
to transl to them was you know these are
the things we need to do to overcome to
get to a point where this is going to be
interesting for them and in reality we
sold the company six months later to the
same buyer okay so so I think there's a
few things here that you have to put in
place one is ability to listen Okay
second ability to relate
listen it's again as I said it's very
challenging okay and we have some we
need to have some humility in this
discussion okay it's about I understand
your situation it's about I understand
why is this is so challenging for you
here are a few few tips from you know
stuff I've done in the past um either
myself or based on my perspective from
other companies I'm working with because
you know again investors have
perspective because they work with
dozens of companies where Founders
usually bet on their own company so I
mean that's a bit of a difference
between the two right um you know a
Founders living within within a boundary
of a company we get to see what other
things succeed or fail in other areas
which are quite similar many times so we
can advise you with plus we have our own
experience so that's the what we add to
the table we have perspective we have
historical perspective we have our own
perspective we have our own experience
and we have portfolio perspective okay
so listening being able to relate to
your situation being able to share with
you different ways to handle the
situation being able to actually show
you obstacle you are not seeing okay
it's like you know I will say this I I I
love working with Founders that are very
have very strong conviction know what
they want to do but also relate to you
know I might come and say hey here's
here's a tree in the middle of the road
you're not seeing it okay it's coming at
you okay now some people are are very
Vain and they'll just avoid it and just
hit the tree um I mean the smartest ones
will say okay what a minute I see what
you're saying let's find together a way
to go around this okay um and this is
kind of the discussion we're having on
an normal basis I love it I you touched
on something that I think is really
interesting which is the question of
relatedness it feels like a lot of the
added value that that you would bring to
the table and and any you know great VC
for an early stage company for that
matter is the advice that the fact that
you have this big wide Viewpoint of the
market today you have your own
experience exactly what you're
mentioning you have the perspectives
that people that are bound to just their
own internal Echo chamber right and and
the the way that I like to think you
know the my investors like to to drink
to drink our own Kool-Aid um it's it's
incredible perspective because
effectively it feels like you're
probably the most knowledgeable person
on the compound who also has the most
incentive to help but you're relate but
the way that you experience the company
is within its borders and you get to
constantly see how it relates to the
external world how do you but it goes
back to this to the fact that the
entrepreneur has to feel like you relate
to them in a way that your advice and
your inputs can then make sense so that
they would be willing to see the tree
and want to engage in a conversation
about the
how if we now look at it from the
perspective of Founders and
entrepreneurs what are ways in which you
think Founders can assess when engaging
with potential Partners to go on this
journey with with potential VCS how can
they assess the the notion of
relatedness of of whether there's this
alignment where this partnership will
work on a personal basis because it
feels like that's a really big part of
being able to then open up and see the
big world yeah absolutely I think that's
what I tell what I tell Founders a lot
of you know most of the time by the way
my my wife is also founder of a very
successful company called TPAC Corp
they're doing composable Plastics and so
fortunately I'm also on on her board
she's she's asked me to join her board
which is kind of awkward in a way but
but I think uh I'm able to also tell her
through the years when she raised uh you
know funds um these points about uh
really connecting with with the with the
investor okay and if it doesn't it
doesn't sit well if the friction is
there already in the internal initial
discussions you know as they say you
know like a gun that a gun or a knife
that that appears in the in the First
Act of the play uh will shoot at a
certain point um so so I think if it
doesn't sit well in the relationship is
not flowing and the trust is not there
uh just don't do it I mean I I think you
know in
way in a way it's such a long journey
and you know we're early stage investors
so typic even most importantly would be
your your earliest investors are the
ones that are matter most for you for
the for the first half of the journey
let's call it um and so and that sets
the scene okay it sets the scene on the
legal terms of the deal which you know
is it friendly or not is it founder
friendly is it aggressive or not that
sets to scene to everybody else down the
road so you know at L we try to be as
friendly as we can not just in terms of
relationship and how we build a
relationship but also in the legal
structure of the deal etc because that
means that we are actually very aligned
with the founders even financially okay
um because we're you know on the cap
tables we're as close as it gets to to
the common shares right to the founders
themselves so so the point is uh it is a
relationship and you know life is short
we we we've very much focused on Amazing
Founders that have amazing conviction on
disrupting Industries Etc but we also
want to enjoy the journey we know it's a
tough Journey we know we're going to
have to work hard but we want to work
with people that we feel good about okay
like we said life is short and so why
get into a relationship where things are
not that don't seem to be call it
flowing okay so I I think it's a mutual
thing I mean my advice to any founder is
really really understand you know the
people you're working with if there's
good vibe you know go for it if if there
isn't move to the next investor and you
know at L we actually give all founders
we talk to the list of all of our
Founders and they can talk to them
themselves we we don't tell them talk to
these guys or these guys so that there's
no bias okay and you know at the end of
the day uh it this is so
critical because um if you don't have a
sounding board in this tough
Journey uh it's just going to be tougher
that's all and there it's tough anyhow
that's a the yeah the a common advice
that I've been getting myself as an
entrepreneur recently quite a lot is
that you know there's so many hard
things about this journey and it's so
difficult as is you know what any
whatever any interaction you can have
with your team with your investors with
customers you know choose the path of
least resistance in many cases that
that'll be good advice because it's it's
hard enough as it is you don't need to
add an additional strain on on the
toughness of it to wrap things up what
what is the biggest really I think the
biggest lesson fundamentally about this
journey of Entrepreneurship that you've
you've accumulated over the years that
you take with you if there's you know if
you're sitting with coffee with an
average per the average young
entrepreneur going on their first
journey what what does it come down to
for you so you know I I I I think the
the bottom line is that we seek for
people that that are very Visionary like
they see a Clear Vision where the world
is heading but we clearly seek for
people that are very passionate as well
in what they do uh that we would feel
that they have the tenacity the
conviction and the resilience ions for
the journey okay um we seek for people
by the way this is not just about talk
about the relationship earlier right
just going pounding back on that but uh
this is not about about just being a
cheerleader on the side you know we we
you seek for people that are ready for
the challenge and ready to be challenged
you know some of our meetings we're
challenging each other in a good way
okay if you're seeking for just a
cheerleader somebody's just going to sit
down and say you're great great great um
I don't think that's that's the right
thing for for for for this relationship
so keep keep that in mind I didn't want
to mean that we're cheerleader on the
contrary we're challenging and Founders
like that challenging in a way that
opens up new thinking processes is key
so we also SE for for for seek for
Founders that are open to be challenged
okay that that are ready to take a
challenge and think about it together in
a way
of of you know mentoring each other and
challenging each other to resolve and
get better and accelerate and move
faster okay so you know in a way this is
you could say this is like uh people
that are open to feedback you know in a
way okay uh but I think it's much more
than that you know it's it's a mutual
discussion it's it's an you know a
company is an organic organic entity it
has a life uh the Founders are the ones
that are planting the DNA into this
company and into this
entity and uh in order for it to execute
well it has to be very well synchronized
orchestrated communicated and driven
forward so we're we're there to try to
help on that thank you so much this is
such a great
conversation I can uh you can only
imagine how how lucky the entrepreneurs
get to work with you are and uh just you
but with L Ventures and I've been very
excitedly following L's Investments and
journey over the last several years ever
since I've gotten into this world myself
uh so and I I've even been to your roof
several times and so it's a highly
recommended experience and thank you
very very much for being here appreciate
it you're welcome to join us again to
our rooftop meetups we do quite a lot of
those some are some are uh specific and
thematics some are just networking and
connecting Founders and investors so
yeah great conversation thank you again
Matias and and have a great day thank
you so much
[Music]